[موسيقى]
هذا الطريق ارى شخصيا انه المفروض يسجل
بالتراث العالمي لماذا لانه يعود لالاف
السنين
وهذا العمل الهندسي يسمى
باللغه الفرنسيه والانجليزيه زقزاق يعني
الطريقه اللي على حرف زد وهو بالضبط على
نفس حرف زد العجيب والغريب ان هذا الاسم
زكزاك هو باللغه العربيه الزقاق هو الطريق
الضيق وفعلا طريق ضيق سواء نافذ او غير
نافذ
[موسيقى]
في الجهه الغربيه لحجر اليمامه طريق يشق
جبل العارض صاعدا الى هضبه نجد مشكلا
المدخل الاشهر والاقدم الى المدينه الخصبه
ذات الانهار والاشجار كما وصفها الرحاله
ابن بطوطه طريق سلكته قوافل التجاره
والجيوش والحجاج لم يبقى من اثرهم الا
اصوات ابليلهم وخيولهم وضجيج تختلط فيه
كلمات بيع وشراء ومنافسه وانتصار وعباده
وبينها ابيات قصائد مديح وحنين وحب انها
طريق ابا القند
فارق الاهه
ري وهو للجمال الاتيه من الحجاز والاتيه
من الخليج العربي مرورا بحجر اليمامه من
الحجاز لحجر اليمامه ومن الخليج العربي
لحجر اليمامه ثم الحجاز قبل الاسلام وبعد
الاسلام استخدموها الحجاج سمي ابا الجد
ابا هي نفس ابو لكنها
منصوبه بالالف للعلميه فاباء او ابو نفس
الشيء
[موسيقى]
القلب باللغه العربيه يعني الشق والتقطيع
وجبل العارض هذا شوق من اجل هذا الطريق
الاثري العظيم طبعا في عده تسميات يقولون
انه بسبب الحبل المصنوعه من الجلد والتي
كانت تربط بها الاحمال والابل
تتمايل هكذا مع هذه الزوايا فيتقطع الجلد
فسمي ابا القد لا هو الصحيح القد قال
تعالى سوره يوسف
وقدت قميصه قدت قطعت قدت قميصه من دبر
فالاسم قد يعني شق في هذا الجبل العظيم
وهو من اقوى واهم الطرق في عده طرق
وهذا الطريق
والمنجور
[موسيقى]
ليس بناء برجيا رفيعا ولا صرحا عملاقا
ولكن بلا شك هو تحفه معماريه عانقت الجبل
واصبحت قطعه منه طريق كان جبليا وعرا طوع
الانسان من اجله الطبيعه فحوله الى مرصوف
مؤمن مدرج على جوانبه جدران وفي بعض
زواياه استراحات للتجار والحجاج وايبيليهم
وله فتحات لتسهيل مرور مياه السيول ولان
هذا الطريق يكشف الاتيين من الجهه الغربيه
وهو بوابه مهمه لحجر اليمامه قديما الرياض
حديثا لذلك هذا الطريق على مر العصور
تاتيه سيول جارفه
فتخربه رغم انه مرثوق ومبني بقوه لذلك في
الدوله السعوديه الاولى ايام اما
السعوديين في الدوله السعوديه الاولى
قاموا بترميم هذا الطريق وذكر بن بشر ايام
الامام عبد العزيز بن محمد بن سعود يقول
لو ضاعت شاه حتى اليمن لما استطاع احد
يمسها لانتشار العدل وانتشار الامن لان
هذا الطريق لا يسلك الا بامن وفي الدوله
السعوديه الثانيه الامام فيصل بن تركي
اعاد ترميم الطريق وتعبيده ثم في الدوله
السعوديه الثالثه المؤسس المغفور له الملك
عبد العزيز رحمه الله جميعا في
الثلاثينيات الميلاديه قام بعمل اخر واخير
اخر من قام بتعبيده هو الملك عبد العزيز
واقاموا هنا عمال مهر اشهر طويله لان
الطريق طويل جدا
فقاموا بتعبيده وتامينه للحجاج ومسافرين
بعدين طلعت السيارات
ثم حفر طريق الجديه للان طريق اديراب اللي
تنزل معاه السيارات وهجر هذا الطريق لكنه
يبقى اثرا انسانيا حضاريا معماريا مهما
على مستوى العالم
[موسيقى]
من الاشياء الجميله اننا في وسط نجد على
هذه الهضبه الجيريه اللي هي جبل طويق التي
تمتد 800 كيلو من الشمال الى الجنوب وهي
من جهتها الغربيه واقفه شاخصه مرتفعه
معترضه لذلك نجدها هذه الدروب التي تصعد
اليها محفوره بالصخر شيء عجيب احنا لسنا
في المرتفعات الجنوبيه الغربيه من المملكه
انما في وسط نجد لكنك عندما تاتي للرياض
من الجهه الغربيه
لابد ان تصعد اليها صعودا
وترتقي يا ارتقاء رغم انها في هضبه نجد
التي يعتقد كثير من الناس انه ارض منبسطه
لا هي فعلا مرتفعه الهضبه لكن
حجر اليمامه من شده تامينها
تامينها الطبيعي اللي خلقه الله لجبل طويق
جعلها من الجهه الغربيه ممتنعه معترضه
فلا تستطيع ان تاتي اليها الا ان تصعد
اليها صعودا من هذه الطرق من الجنوب الى
الشمال نعيد ونكرر ادراب ابا القد مسيعط
درب زبيده
السقطه المنجور ومن العوده الطبيعيه لكن
بعيده هذه اكثر اختصارا الاوديه الطبيعيه
واديبرك وادي الاوسط من الجنوب الى الشمال
وادي
بضيق الملوات اللي هو في وادي لحا
وثنيه الحيسيه هذه منافذ طبيعيه لكنها
بعيده جدا لتدخل الى حجر اليمامه فهذه
الطرق اسرع
واخسر لكنها اصعب وبناءها يدل على حضاره
عظيمه سادت في حجر اليمامه منذ الاف
السنين
[موسيقى]
فرش الانسان هذا الطريق امام احدى بوابات
اليمامه لكنه لم يترك دليلا قاطعا عن عمره
الدقيق ليختلف الباحثون حوله للبحث في
التاريخ البعيد للمنطقه ذهبنا الى قبيلتين
كانت اليمامه موقع استقرارهما وخلافهما
وحروبهما حتى اندثرته انهما قبلتا تصم
وجديس ولكن ما علاقه القبيلتين بطريق ابا
القد وما الرابط بين الطريق والهيكل
الحجري العملاق المبني افقيا على سطح
الجبل عن ما ضاع من تاريخ بوابه حجر
اليمامه خطا يوافقها عيد اليحيى تحت الحجر
وفوقه
عمل في العصر الاسلامي وهذا ليس صحيح لانه
لم يثبت ان الضوء العصر الخلفاء الراشدين
او الدوله الامويه شق الطريق في هذا الجبل
الشاهر جبل طويق باتجاه الرياض حجر
اليمامه طوله كيلو متر واحد هذا هذا اقيم
في وقت استقرار ووقت خصب ووقت قوه
اقتصاديه ومعروف ان طسم وجديس اللي
استقروا في اليمامه كانوا امه عمرانيه
وفي دليل اخر على قدمه هو المدفن مدفن
دائري ذو ذيل في اعلى الجبل وهذا المدفن
عمل بجانب الطريق فلا يمكن ان يكون هذا
المدفن لم يعمل بسبب وجود الطريق هما
مشتركان مع بعض وهذا المدفن يعود لعصور
قديمه جدا لان الانماط الموجوده من هذا
المدفن في عموم الجزيره العربيه في حاره
خيبر في حرار اخرى يعود عمرها الخمسه الاف
سنه من الوقت الحاضر فهو ربما عمره خمسه
الاف سنه او 4000 سنه وهذا قديم بسبب
المدفن لانه نفس النمط اقيس وفحص او يعود
العصر طسم وجديس اللي هو الالف قبل
الميلاد يعني ثلاثه الاف سنه من الوقت
الحاضر
[موسيقى]
ارتقى فريق على خطى العرب طريق ابا القد
حتى قمته ليسجل اكتشافا على سطح الجبل بين
صخوره تاريخ مكتوب بلا كلمات
هنا يعود الزمن الى الرحله السابعه التي
وثقت هياكل حجريه تحاول السماء ربما بنيت
لحياه اخرى بعد الموت هياكل في دوائرها
تدور الالغاز والتساؤلات
[موسيقى]
اكتشفنا اكتشاف مهم
اثري مهم
الصاعد
من درب ابا القد التاريخي المنجور المحفور
بالصخر في صفحه جبل طويق
والمرصوف والمبني بجدران اول ما يصعد
الصاعد او النازل نجد على فم الطريق على
ظهره الجبل سطح الجبل
نجد مدفا دائري في وسطه دائره انا الان
على الدائره وله ذيل
مسنن عقدي يمتد لمسافه واحد كيلو متر واحد
ماذا يدل ذلك هل هذا المدفن بني صدفه
بجانب درب ابا القد او ان جبل او ان طريق
ابا القد حفر صدفه بجانب المدفن لا طبعا
لا يمكن
مئات الكيلومترات لماذا هذا المدفن عند فم
الطريق ارى شخصيا وهذا بحثناه في الجزء
السابع من خطى العرب عن تاريخ المدافن ان
الذي بنى المدفن عند فهم الطريق كان
الطريق موجوده اثناء المدفن ولا لماذا
اختار هذا الموقع عند المدفن مع ان عنده
خشوم كثيره
ورعان كثيره لجبل طويق وهذا المدفن الان
ثبت ليس فحصي ثبت ان هذه المدافن لا يقل
عمرها عن خمسه الاف عام من الوقت الحاضر
برونز او عصر حجري
[موسيقى]
اذا هذا المدفن التاريخي
مربوط في درب ابا القد التاريخي طيب اذا
معنى ذلك وكررنا ذلك في مواسم سابقه تاريخ
الجزيره العربيه لم يعطى حقه وربما لم
يدرس بعد
سواء درب اديراب من الشرق من الجنوب عن
دربب الجد يعني عده الطرق المحفوره
الاثريه والتي تصعد وتنزل على حجر اليمامه
قديما
درب اديراب وهذا عمل والان طبعا السيارات
حفرته وازيل الدرب التاريخي للاسف
درب ابا القد يعني من الجنوب الى الشمال
اديراب
مصيعط
زبيده زبيده غير السيده زبيده درب الحج
الكوفي السقطه المنجور كلها بقيت الا درب
اديره بوزيل لكن بقيت الدروب لكن اهمها
واوضحها الى اليوم دربه بالقد يتجه شرقا
الى وسط الرياضه عبر اوديه نمر سبحان الله
لما تنظر من جوجل تجد هذه الدروب كلها
تلتقي في نقاط متقاربه لتدخل وسط الرياض
حاليا حجر اليمامه قديما كيف متروها كيف
عرفوها لذلك لماذا انا قلت ان هذا المدفن
لم يوجد اعتباطا بجانب درب لان كلها عملت
في حضاره واحده اذا هذا عمره 5000 سنه
وهذا هو الث في مقارنه بالمدافن الكثيره
معنى ذلك ان دربه بلغت ومعنى ذلك ان حجر
اليمامه موجوده قبل الف سنه قبل الميلاد
يعني ليس فقط قسم جديد الف قبل الميلاد
3000 سنه من الوقت الحاضر انما اقدم بكثير
لذلك يجب اعاده
دراسه هذا التاريخ او كل هذه الطرق التي
تصعد الى اليمامه كلها طرق تاريخيه ضاربه
في القدم
[موسيقى]
اذا نظرنا اليه من امام العارض او من
سمائه من اي زاويه نراه تشكيلا فنيا
منسجما مع ثنايا الجبل معا يشكلان ثنائيا
احدهما اي الجبل سمح للاخر بان يتدخل في
طبيعته ويحفر ويبني ويرصف والاخر اي
الطريق فتمايل مع تضاريس الاول حتى تعانق
من القدمين وحتى الراس هناك خلف جبل
العارض هبطت الخطى في حضن اليمامه حيث
تلتقي الوديان في نسيج شد التاريخ الحديث
للجزيره العربيه
كما ترون خلفنا درب ابا القد التاريخي
الاثري يخترق صفحه جبل طويق بخط مستقيم
الذين اختاروه ونحتوه ونجروا وقصوا الجبل
ليس فقط رصفا وبناء جدران انما مقص للصخر
بطريقه مستقيم شرقا الى حجر اليمامه عبر
وادي نمار والطرق الاخرى لكن ما الذي
يهمنا يهمنا ان هناك تنظيم لصعود القوافل
فيها اشخاص في الاعلى وفي الاسفل لانه اذا
اتت قافله من الرياض من حجر اليمامه قديما
لابد ان تتوقف القافله اللي تحت واذا صعدت
قافله لابد ان تتوقف القافله النازله فهو
في غرف الان ظاهر اعلاها في الاسفل هذه
يدل انه في ناس يقيمون في هذا المكان لكن
ما الاهميه لذلك
خطى العرب وكالعاده يكتش ف
امور كثيره مهمه جدا
هذا الطريق كتب من عمره 1400 سنه اصلا في
الدوله الامويه او في الخلفاء عهد الخلفاء
الراشدين رضي الله عنه لم يعهد ان اليمامه
حفر فيها هذا الطريق ولم يعمل في بلاد
اخرى هذا الطريق اقيم ايام حضاره قويه
وغنى اقتصادي
اللي اكتشفوا خطى العرب المدفن الدائري ذو
الذيل طوله كيلو متر فوق الطريق مباشره
فهذا اكتشاف يفتح الافاق لتحديد هذا العمر
وانه يتجاوز الاف السنين وباقي لليوم عمل
له تجديد نعم ايام الدوله السعوديه الاولى
والثانيه والثالثه لكنه
قديم جدا وليس عمره 1400 سنه والذين
اختاروه اختاروه بطريق مستقيم الى حجر
اليمامه
[موسيقى]